and fourth quarter comes around and kobe
looks at me and he's like
are you guys staying the night tonight
and i'm like
i'm looking at my kill make sure he's
not looking at me for me i'm like yeah
like what up
like
i'm like oh [ __ ] he's doing it like he's
mr miyagi and me right now it's like
he's doing i'm like yeah
what's up we're staying
he goes i'll set you up like i'll get
your number from jay chill and like
if you want to go out tonight i'm like
stop like you're like i know what you're
doing like come on
mchale's over there like grilling me
like stop talking this [ __ ]
so i go ends up he ends up just going
off he's like 40 that game we lose after
the game you know like right there in
l.a live we go to like katsuya
and
we're with all the ogs right we're with
like can be down and they're all taking
me out i get a text and it goes you're
all set at supper club
dash mamba and i'm like
i'm like i'm like looking around like
all right who's [ __ ] with me like no
no way
and but i'm like courtney lee was my guy
right i'm like showing him like is this
real like it's real like you got his
number like and i write him back i'm
like okay like or like are you like i
said something are you commenting he's
like no i can't make it but my guy will
hit you up
got next text hey you're set up let me
know what you need a super club whatever
so at this point i'm telling the table
i'm like guys i got you
i hope he's my guy he set it up let's go
jb
jamie bickerstaff is there like i'm
bringing coaches i'm bringing trainers
this is i got it
and we have a blast right we have the
craziest night ever supper club was the
tape was the club where the the tables
were beds yeah yeah it was awesome i was
like it was nuts
and
2 a.m rolls around
and
grant i'm with these guys that made
hundreds of millions of dollars and this
waitress bee lines right to me with the
check and i'm like oh [ __ ] and my dad's
my financial advisor at the time he
would be on my ass if i like value size
my combo meal chick-fil-a and he's
bringing me she's bringing me this bill
for god knows how much
and i'm like oh man
i open it
i open it
and it's like 22 thousand dollars
and now at this point i'm like i'm sick
i'm physically like no no like i can't
do this because card's gonna bounce
and i'll never forget this chick looks
at me
hands me a pen and says sign for mr
bryant
and i'm like
what i'm like video the whole thing i'm
like
i'm like signing kobe bryant i signed
kobe bryant on a 22 000 club bill and
everyone by the way they say he's tough
he's going to go at you i'm like this
dude was cool as [ __ ] he was dope he was
awesome
it was a crazy crazy time
i got a picture of it for sure
i still got his number like i'm like i
love the way the story went though
because i thought because kobe was an
ass too he would have been lucky with
the bill and his bill from the weekend
before i was like